behind these rocks there's an
interdimensional portal and that portal
will lead us directly to The Monitor.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my flash season 6 episode 6
video there were a whole bunch of Easter
eggs we also have a bunch of Batman and
Superman crisis on Infinite Earths
teaser so I'll break that down during
the video too if you're new to the
channel we're doing a flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the episode on the video
careful for spoilers if you had not seen
the episode yet we'll do top 10 and
easter eggs then I'll talk about all the
Batman Superman crisis teasers starting
with number 10 the title of the episode
license to elongate obviously a
reference to license to kill lots of
James Bond references with the Barry
elongated man's storyline this week it
was a flash elongated man team-up
episode for the most part there was a
lot of stuff going on with the other
storylines not all them were great but I
do feel like they pushed forward pretty
good into crisis on Infinite Earths
because we're only a couple weeks away
from that happening number 9 Nash wells
explains his plan and why he has to get
past that special wall to get to the
monitor so his whole thing is is the
monitor has a portal that will take them
directly to the special space where
Barry and Oliver talked to him during
last year's crossover remember when they
went to the elevator in an instantly
teleported them to his platform in a
different part of space-time that's
exactly what's behind this wall that's
why Nash wells wants to get there so bad
the eternium laced rocks apparently have
anti vibrational properties so there's
no way that the flash can just run right
through the monitor is probably doing
that to keep any speedsters from getting
through not just the good speedsters
like Barry Allen but also people like
reverse-flash other evil speedsters
number 8 Chester P run finishes baking
in their oven at STAR Labs and it seems
like they're setting him up to maybe
replace Cisco on team flash either later
to this year or after a crisis on
Infinite Earths at some point there were
just too many scenes during the episode
where he's a super sciency tech guy
they've already established that he's
super smart he's really good at
engineering things like Cisco does he
does a lot of the same things that Cisco
does and he's super excited at the idea
of being on STAR Labs when cecile
mentions it at the end of the episode
which I did kind of take issue with a
little bit but just because I don't
think cecile has the authority to offer
people membership
on Team flash he just bring in anybody
that she wants oh hey you on the street
even the other core members of the team
Caitlin and Cisco haven't willy nilly
just brought somebody else onto the team
without Barry doing it himself I think
that's mostly the riders just letting
you know that he's definitely going to
be joining team flash really soon and
they wouldn't have spent so much time
developing his character through the
episode as part of this as steal
storyline finding out who I'm going to be
working on his comedic timing he even
makes Star Wars references like Cisco
when he references I feel kind of like
Alderaan on a bad day from Star Wars a
new hope everything about his storyline
just screams that he is going to replace
someone on Team flash and who is the
other tech guy on team flash right now
that's Cisco
so either Cisco winds up retiring and
leaving team flash or r.i.p cisco during
crisis on Infinite Earths everyone post
your Cisco predictions on the video
though
but number seven elongated man's new
emblem as the official new protector of
the city Orko protector with Barry Allen
the way they worked it out in that press
conference at the end is that he's also
a protector now not the protector
because Barry thinks he's going to die in a
little while he just wants there to be
some seamless transition like oh the
city still has a protector an elongated
man if I do go out during this big fight
the emblem itself probably just works
like his emblem they always built tech
into it little communicators or any
special technology for defeating the
villain of the week depending on who it
is number six the suit did nice
storyline all the James Bond black hole
and ultraviolet come back we learned
that the suit did knee character or sue
Dearborn whatever you want to call her
from the comics has been missing for the
past six months or so but she's this
former socialite who has a bit of a bad
girl reputation but her disappearance
seems somewhat tied to the activities of
black hole and the ultraviolet character
so it's all connected and then he later
tells iris at the end of the episode
that the black hole emblems showed up
with ultraviolet at the parties so iris
is also on that case too they've already
cast the suit Dib knee character but I
don't know which episode she's going to
debut and it's this actress here so this
is what she's going to look like the
dress that she was last seen in made by
Victoria Vale is a Batman in 1989 Vicki
Vale reference there were a ton of James
Bond references shaken not stirred there
was a whole bunch of Goldfinger later in
the episode
Ralph even verbally calls him out on it
come on that's a line
directly out of Goldfinger the laser
itself is also directly from that scene
in Goldfinger where he's trying to end
James Bond number five the Nashville's
Alegre team-up so they kind of have a
funny introduction she doesn't know
anything about the multiverse or
doppelgangers aren't you supposed to be
Harrison wells didn't you die there were
a lot of funny moments during their
storyline but the real was him just
sort of giving away the farm to her
willy-nilly like telling her Barry Allen
is the flash wait a minute you're
telling me that my boss's husband is the
flash so another person now knows his
secret identity but he also lays so much
knowledge on her so fast about the
monitor about crisis on Infinite Earths
so it sounds like they intend for this
Allegra character to be way way bigger
this season but I'm assuming that she'll
probably wind up being involved with
taking down the ultraviolet character
for good like she'll learn about her
powers then eventually the two of them
will face off so instead of the flash
ultimately beating ultraviolet when they
start getting into the black hole
storyline later this season it'll be the
Allegra character to do it
also big when they make the
Mythbusters reference about Nash wells
taking down the monitor busting MS he
also implies that he's going to try and
end the monitor this just seems like
it's all setting him on the path to
become the pariah character it does seem
for now like he might wind up turning
into comic book pariah and that'll be
his penance for what he's trying to do
to the monitor number 4 was all the
Chester P trunk Cyrano de Bergerac stuff
with the coffee they tried to turn it
into this big funny moment with Cecile
speaking into his ear telling him what
the thing apparently Cecile can now use
her ability through the telephone I
don't think that was a thing before it
shouldn't work that way but it didn't
work during the episode so it kind of
makes sense that it didn't work but
again this was all I think just part of
the idea of you developing that
character and setting up the idea that
it wouldn't be weird if he showed up on
team flash in the future I just didn't
like the way they handled that storyline
and they try to get you really invested
in what's going on with the seals
character in this part of the episode
only really works if you really really
care what happens to Cecile and she's
not really even that big of a member of
team flash so it is kind of strange
number 3 was the big Ring of Fire
satellite that they were auctioning off
they were blowing up half of Central
City just to demo it for all the people
that were bidding on it but it's also a
reference
the brother eyes satellite from the
comics because they call it ey e as in
brother I which is also tied to the
identity crisis storyline and Infinite
Crisis which kind of gets into soo
didney crossover but they're not doing
the direct identity crisis storyline
that's just something that happened in
the comics before Infinite Crisis and
obviously Infinite Crisis is a
completely separate storyline from
crisis on Infinite Earths but the TV
version of crisis will combine a whole
bunch of different storylines but number
two they go full mortal combat on stage
with Barry versus their version of
Melina in ultraviolet that's the
reference that they're making oh I love
mortal combat finish him he also makes a
Price is Right reference when he's
pretending to be drunk bidding on the
weapon to just draw things out longer
and longer the woman in red to kind of
nods to them and then walks away making
it seem like she might become a bigger
character later this season as part of
the black hole storyline with the
ultraviolet character remember the black
hole organization is really big in the
flash rebirth comics it goes way bigger
there's a couple other big speedster
characters tied to it so it just seems
like they're setting them up for the
back half of the season it's too soon
for them to debut right before the
crossover then number one was the
post-credits scene with ramsey Rossa
going full blood work on ralph dragging
him over the balcony in the whole idea
that they seem like they're implying
negative flash either in next week's
episode or the episode after that the
actual description for the mid-season
finale before the big crossover episode
really does sound like full negative
flash so either is happening next week
or the week after that but just keep
your eyes peeled if you're a big fan of
the negative flash from the flash
rebirth comics they'll do a version of
that with Barry Allen for getting into
all the crisis on Infinite Earths
teasers they dropped this morning we got
our first look at Tom Welling as
Smallville Superman during the crossover
wearing the classic flannel wielding an
axe seeming like he's just chopping wood
on his version of the Kent farm on
Smallville's earth whichever a
designation they're going to give that in
the multiverse there's a couple pictures
of Tyler hoechlin Superman with Lois
Lane and iris West so it seems like iris
travels around to a couple different
places picking up these people she also
might be one of the people to travel to
kingdom come Superman's earth the
newspaper behind him here too is also an
Easter Egg for Kingdom Come Superman's
origin story of Sora's how he goes from
being regular super
to kingdom come post-apocalyptic
Superman the origin story itself is
borrowed directly from the kingdom come
comic book story so they have mark
Wade's name on it he's the person that
wrote this article within the world of
the show but Mark Waid in real life also
wrote the Kingdom Come comic book the
story is all about the Joker gas bombing
the Daily Planet ending a bunch of
people including Lois Lane and that
leads Superman to become super depressed and going into isolation eventually
adopting the new darker version of his
uniform to honor the people that had
fallen and then coming back out of
isolation as part of the big Kingdom
Come event so it sounds like that's why
he's wearing this version of the costume
instead of his classic Superman costume
because Brandon Routh is playing his
version of Superman from Superman
Returns but one of the showrunners Marc
Guggenheim also confirmed this canonical
reference to that his version of
Superman is also meant to be the same
version of Superman as Christopher
Reeves so it's basically saying that
Christopher Reeves Superman eventually
becomes Kingdom Come Superman the Batman teaser actually looks like it's Kevin
Conroy doing his version of Batman but
it's also a bit of a Kingdom Come
reference because he's wearing that
special harness exoskeleton around him
so I'm kind of expecting him to be an
amalgam of a couple different versions
of Batman but I don't know if he also
comes from this earth where Brandon
brows Superman is coming from there'll
be more crisis on Infinite Earths
trailer and teaser videos in the next
week or two so of course I'll do videos
for all that stuff there were more
crisis teasers I'll talk about those
during my flash trailer video tomorrow
so as long as you've turned alerts on
for my channel you'll see those videos
when I post them
everybody click here for my brand new
Rick and Morty season 4 episode 3
trailer video and click here for the
brand new Star Wars the Mandalorian Episode 2
video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!